in my hero academia the paranormal
liberation war has been one of the best
storylines we've seen for a long time
and since the beginning there's been a
ton of bizarre new quirks introduced to
the series today I'm gonna talk about
the ones that I personally like the most
and do my best to explain their full
capabilities based on what we've seen
for those of you who only watch the
anime though there will be big spoilers
in this video so if you don't want to
know I suggest you pause this video and
wait maybe two to three years for season
six to be animated I'm sorry guys but
it's gonna take a long time for this to
hit the screen for the rest of you as of
making this video the war Ark hasn't
finished yet in the manga so these
quirks are my personal favorites so far
but I'm sure there will be many more to
come
just before we get into it shout out to
Rach other legends for sponsoring this
video
raid is completely free to download
available on both mobile and desktops
although I personally just play on my
phone there are loads of ongoing
tournaments including the dragon
tournament the spider's den the ice
golems peak that this goes on people
also because of their new patch on the
game there will be a brand new arena
tournament coming but you can win
awesome prizes such as these shards here
in the game you can redeem these shards
to get new champions to fight with on
this occasion I unlocked this guy called
coffin Smasher who I definitely would
not want attending my funeral if you
clicked this special link in my
description then you automatically have
10 of these mystery shards as well as
100,000 free coins and if we champion
called the executioner who again sounds
like a lovely guy this offer is only
available for the next 30 days so be
sure to check it out as these bonuses
will make your starts in the game way
easier okay so the first quote that we
have in this list belongs to a character
on the hero side and this guy
immediately caught my attention we first
saw him when the heroes began to storm
the paranormal Liberation Front mansion
and his costume design I just gotta say
it is top tier many chapters after this
initial storming of the mansion we saw
his quirk in action and it has to be one
of the most unique powers to exist in
this universe out of the back of his
hands he can summon these stretchy blue
creatures that can chase off the people
and swallow them up as mr. compress says
in this panel each of these things seem
to have heightened senses which implies
to me that they are alive in some way
and that they have independent thoughts
separate to the user which wouldn't be
too strange and in fact I think it would
be quite similar to the way that dark
shadow can think independently of Tokyo
me and he more so chooses to listen to
what Tokyo me says rather than being you
know some kind of robot that has to
listen to what Takayama says but anyway
back to these blue stretchy things their
teeth don't seem to be very sharp as
they were able to clamp down on toga and
compress without causing them any damage
and judging from what the hero who had
this quirk said it's clear that they can
swallow up people without harming them
so it's more of a method of storage
rather than you know a fatal thing my
assumption is that once they eat someone
this guy can then retract them back into
his hand and store them for later in a
similar way to how compressed stores
people and you know giant objects inside
his tiny marbles I think this would work
in a similar way sadly though we won't
be seeing this quirk in action ever
again as the guy who had it was killed
by twice literally just stabbed in the
back of the head like pretty brutal
stuff after this fatal attack the
creatures let go of the villains and
just slumped to the ground so yeah they
were dead the user was dead everyone was
dead
hell even twice was dead still though
this is one of the best new abilities
from this art and I personally thought
it was super creative now moving on to
my actual favorite quote from this whole
storyline this belongs to a certain high
in no move for the purposes of this
video we're gonna call him Dave as many
of you know I had high hopes for Dave
whilst he was yet another casualty of
miracles thick thighs his gravity
warping quirk was absolutely amazing
with this power he can stick out his arm
and then warp the space in a chosen
location we saw this during the battle
at jakku hospital he was standing on one
side of the lab whilst Mirko was
standing many meters away attacking a
different nomu as she was about to
deliver the finishing blow
Dave activated this warping quirk and
manipulated the space around miracles
arm look at the way her bone is twisting
here like is literally being sucked in
like a black hole as we can see here
Dave then twisted his wrist which had
the effect of ripping half of mirko's
arm off my interpretation of that is
that when he twists his hand like this
for warped spaces then cut off so
anything that's been pulled in he's just
gone it's just disappeared that would
explain why the rest of our
armed is nowhere to be seen Dave also
had another cool quark which gave him a
pair of these deadly laser eyes
coincidentally this quirk was also
possessed by one of the heroes in this
arc called Excellus although technically
his was like a demo version of the for
quark because he could only use it in
one eye Excellus has actually made an
appearance in the anime before and I'm
gonna be completely honest I didn't even
notice him but someone on Twitter
mentioned it so I thought I'd throw it
in there
despite that previous appearance I'm
fairly certain that the paranormal
liberation war was the first time we
ever actually saw his quark being used
following on from this we have the quark
that was really interesting not just
because of how it works but also because
of everything that it means the ability
in question is called life force and it
allows the holder to double their
lifespan but at the cost of their
physical capabilities what that means in
practice is that whoever has this quirk
basically has lost their chance to be a
famous athlete but on the other side
they live twice as long as they would
have otherwise out of every quark miss
list this one has a very unique history
so bear with me the original version of
this quark was held by dr. Ichigo he
then gave his quark tool for one but
later down the road a copy of this quark
was made and given back to the doctor
this means that from the first moment we
saw these characters they both held some
version of this life force quark the
manga even clarifies that the doctor is
at least 120 years old but as we can see
he looks nothing like that age meanwhile
all-4-one is even older than this which
by my calculations would likely make him
around 117 maybe even at a push 200
years old this quark has allowed both
characters to live well past their
sell-by date what this does is it
further emphasizes the fact that the
battle-ax Camino was between two people
who were who had just so far passed
their best and that's so crazy because
all for one you know he destroyed best
Gina's who was the number four ranked
hero at the time even with all that
stuff going against him
all-4-one is still stronger than the
best pro heroes is pretty insane last
thing to mention about this is that
Aizawa used his eraser quark on dr.
groggy and it revealed what he should
really look like and
yeah it's not good the next power on
this list is called ampere volt and it's
possessed by one of the prominent
members of the paranormal Liberation
Front now this guy's quirk allows him to
absorb electricity and then amplify it
within his own body but unlike
characters like Denki for example he
can't actually create electricity from
scratch so he has to use these tasers as
a support item amplified Ben cranks it
up and allows him to discharge it in an
ultimate move which he calls Thunder net
this quirk initially caught my eye
because of the supreme confidence that
he had in this ability when faced with
an entire army of professional heroes
this guy genuinely seemed to believe
that he could take them all on by
himself which makes me wonder like
surely he has some amazing
accomplishment in his past that that
made him this brave but luckily kaminari
was right there to absorb it all as we
see in this panel he can use at least
six tasers at one time so yeah pretty
interesting quirk obviously it has that
big limitation that he can't create his
own electricity but on the whole pretty
decent it seems that he can go up to you
know several million volts I mean I
would imagine just based on this wording
it seems pretty confident so I'm gonna
say like four or five million perhaps
but that is just speculation
I'll admit that this next one isn't
exactly a new quirk but if you want to
get really pedantic then it kind of is
as you will know all for one is a power
that lets the user steel quarks from
others and then either use it for
themselves or pass it on to someone else
and so far in the series we've seen two
versions of this quark the first time
was with all-4-one and then the second
time was in the heroes rising movie when
nine also had it however both of these
quarks were simply copies of the
original we have never seen the original
or one in the main series of Myer
academia I'm talking in present-day
we've never seen it in action in chapter
270 shigaraki goes into this dreamlike
world sort of like Inception or
something and he rejects his family and
walks into the darkness towards
all-4-one it was at this moment that he
wakes up and has the original alpha one
power so now he has two quarks which are
decay and all for one despite not being
near the hospital deck whose heartbeats
and he's visibly shocked and scared one
Shigure ah he regains consciousness they
are telepathically connected in some way
though
surely not like the Ray in Kyllo type of
way the full capability of the original
alpha one has not yet been revealed as
of making this video but I'd speculate
that it has a bunch of quotes already
stocked up inside it I say this because
during the battle at Kamino if you
remember all for one actually consider
taking best genesis quark but decided
against it because it wouldn't be suited
to sugar aki so what that shows us is
that he was actively looking for quarks
that would be suited for shigaraki and
possibly maybe when he gets them he puts
them back in the original offer one
that's a possibility and seeing as we're
on this speculation train I would
speculate that the overclocked quark
from the vigilantes manga that could be
one of the new quarks that sugar aki
gets it can basically allow people to
move at incomprehensible speeds like so
fast so what if sugar aki has something
like this you can imagine that he could
dust an entire army of pro heroes pretty
quickly but yet the original offer wonk
work haven't yet seen it in the series
so that's why I'm technically counting
it as a new quirk although yes I do
realize I'm kind of cheating here the
next one worth mentioning is a quirk
that really grossed me out and I
actually don't like it but considering
it very nearly killed the number 5 pro
hero I think it does deserve a mention
so this power is held by one of the
margin boo higher noemi's and he is able
to transform this trunk on his head into
a weapon of mass destruction it first
made its debut in chapter 262 where he
grew it into this disgustingly large
size and just split it up into all these
tentacles it was really gross and then
he attacked Mirko with it I'm gonna be
honest I have no idea what this material
is made of I mean is it brain matter
possibly I don't know whatever it is
this quirk is dangerous from long range
and at the beginning Mirko was able to
kick straight through it without much
trouble but as we all know that was
because the higher noemi's hadn't yet
stabilized so they were a bit weak they
weren't fully at their full powers yet
later on in the manga once he you know
gets a bit up to speed then his
tentacles follow Mirko down a dark
hallway and stab her in the leg arm and
torso when we examine the damage Dante
is pretty clear that these are brain
matter tentacle things there's no joke
we also saw that on top of being able to
deliver deadly attacks and like stab
through
people it's also useful for yanking
people back and you know flinging them
around so yeah a pretty good quirk I
mean good for a gnome or at least I
couldn't imagine a normal person with
this just looks so strange okay so
moving on from that this next one I
really like the look of it and also the
look of the character who has it so I
figured I may as well just briefly talk
about it this villain here is a member
of the paranormal Liberation Front as
you would imagine and he made his first
proper appearance in chapter 271
although we did see a preview of him in
Chapter 253 and he seems to be able to
just generate holes inside things maybe
similar to the way that a longer ish
uses spatial magic in black clover
perhaps I love his design and it's very
true to the way that his quark seems to
work getting tells the soldiers to focus
on one point and crack open a hole while
getting may have not been talking
literally when he said to crack open a
hole based on the look on this guy's
face he might have taken it that way
this ability is quite similar to one we
saw in the first Maya academia movie
where this villain he had a similar type
of quirk where he could displace matter
and so he ended up making holes and
things so I'm thinking this quirk might
work in a similar way
now clearly we're not going in
chronological order but technically the
first new power that we learnt of during
this arc was a quirk called float which
is possessed by Nana shamora
and we didn't get too many details on it
beyond just this one page of her
floating in the manga but I think it's
pretty clear that this power allows her
to levitate in the air and it would have
made for a pretty nice combination with
one for all will undoubtably get more
details once Deku begins training with
it and knowing Hiroko she is going to be
a very important power for defeating
shigaraki and i say that because it's
sugar Aki's grandmother's quirk but it's
now possessed by sugar our keys
grandmother's successor which is not him
so that's a pretty interesting dynamic
and yeah I think it will be important
going forward one crucial thing to know
that we don't know yet is whether it can
like propel you forward like Superman or
if it just lets you float in the air
casually hopefully it's the former
because that is just way better anyway
guys for now those were my favorite
quotes from the war arc of Maya academia
mirko isn't on this list because I plan
to do a video dedicated to her and we
already saw her quote during the pro
hero arc so yeah that's why she's not on
this
video like I said my favorite was the
gravity warping quirk but I'm pretty
hard to see what the original awful one
can do as well thanks for watching as
always and peace out